hi guys it's boyz in here and today i
have the 9th generation ipad and we're
going to run a series of gaming tests on
it to see whether it's great for gaming
or not we're going to go from least
intensive to most intensive with games
like mobile legends pubg call of duty
and gentian impact and i'm pretty sure
we did a review on the ipad 8 last year
it worked pretty well exactly
so we're going to see whether this
entry-level ipad 9
works well for gaming as well
let's find out
so let's quickly go in and see what
settings we have
okay
i get it okay fine
all right so everything's on high hd
mode hfr mode graphics on ultra it's
being blocked by the download screen on
here but it says ultra right here so we
have everything set for a live test
so let's get into a casual game a
classic game
so the main thing when it comes to game
tests anything obviously we're looking
for frame drops you're looking for
anything funky
and so far
you know everything looks pretty smooth
you and i both know that ammo doesn't
really take much
to perform on a mobile phone much less
an ipad so i think this should be good
oh okay animations are really smooth
attacks come really clean
there we go
[Music]
all right let me won the game
[Applause]
right so over legends sound is amazing
on the ipad 9 no lag no frame drops
nothing animations are smooth attacks
are clean
you can expect a lot from this mobile
legends is a definite yes on the ipad 9.
right so we have call of duty mobile at
the main page and ghost looks amazing
his gun details the particle effects oh
everything looks great so let's go
straight to the settings
and let's go to graphics
so really it's at the highest graphical
quality however you know you can't run
the very high graphics quality option
together with the highest frame rate
options with max at the same time so
we'll just keep graphics quality at high
because that's what we're here for
and let's check out the other stuff so
we're going to run a multiplayer game
and we're going to set everything on and
the earliest thing doesn't feel
real-time shadows boom dragged all the
whole shebang so let's get into the game
real quick my input looks amazing this
thing
now let's see how it plays
all right touch is hella responsive
know that no frame drops or anything
injured
one
two
right so final thoughts on call of duty
mobile there's no there are no frame
drops particle effects are great my
models look amazing
so yes call of duty mobile it's a
definitely s on the ipad 9. right so
with pubg setup let's go straight into
the graphics settings let's go to
graphics and we're already on smooth and
extreme
movies great anti-aliasing therefore and
we are good to go let's get into the
game yeah like after like playing like
two games on the ipad 9 you know
everything
the whole system feels very smooth and
oh
yeah this is smooth yeah so with the
enhanced frame rate on extreme you know
there are no frame rate drops no lag
nothing on this as well i think without
playing a game we can definitely say
that you know it's a yes this ipad 9 can
definitely take the stream of any game
you throw at it so i'm not too worried
about genji's impact right now
hopefully not
but yeah so the map looks great so far
let's try to jump off
i mean it's it's pop g cloud you know
you're not gonna expect much but you
know so far you know it feels very
smooth
okay let's get some weapons real quick
let's see who else we have oh it's
pretty smooth as well it's like three
four two teams maybe
nice okay let's get in
i have nothing but a pen
yeah you can't work with this
all right let's just go
and we got a painkiller yeah come on
come on give me your stuff
sounds amazing of course responsiveness
on the screen is great
[Applause]
okay i see them
okay i can move around the building here
i do not want to run into them real
quick
oh i'm down damn it so just to wrap up
pubg you know it's smooth it's yes
for the ipad 9. you can shoot impact
among the four games that are playing
demands the most
from the processor and the ipad itself
so we'll see how it shapes up okay so
we're shunning here let's go to the
graphics settings real quick
so we'll see what we can do
let's get let's try the highest then all
right i mean we're overclocking the ipad
9 a bit but you know let's see what we
can get out of it
[Music]
okay that looks
it looks great it's still smooth you
know a bit laggy here and there but
that's because you know we're playing at
the highest set of things
all right i mean combat on ultra high
isn't the best
but
it sure does look good i guess
[Applause]
that's great
[Applause]
but yeah so ultra high not the best
so let's try on high for the next
encounter
let's just switch up to high real quick
i'm going to get ramp yep i got rammed
all right let's go to high
on default ultra high did not look good
at all it's a bit choppy it's a bit
laggy a couple of frame drops here and
there you know it just didn't look good
at all
so we're back in the encounter again
let's get out of the way yeah this feels
a lot smoother
[Music]
[Music]
so yeah there you have it gen chin and
back on high obviously you know it looks
okay if we go closer up you know the
character models look amazing let's
check it out on ultra high real quick
honestly i'd say it's pretty much the
same as playing on high
it was good so far actually yeah i'm
gonna take it back
i wouldn't want to like kill my battery
that quick so i'd rather just play on
high instead no it's just the fact that
on the highest i think my ipad 9 is
being overclocked and you know if i
found a game on the go and i want the
game to look all pretty and stuff
at the cost of my battery life i
wouldn't want to do that because i'm
going for longer so i would keep it at
high
you know it's a lot smoother you get a
little bump in frame rate
so yeah it's a preferential thing you
know it looks good either way on high or
highest
so
against in the back is definitely a game
you can play on the ipad 9.
so final verdict for gaming on the ipad
9 we played like four games it all
turned out gorgeous you don't need to
think twice about gaming on the ipad 9
at all except for genji and pack is a
preferential thing because you know
whether you want to overclock your ipad
or not that's up to you
but either way the game looks gorgeous
no matter what right that wraps up the
video leave a like and subscribe to us
if you haven't it helps us out a lot
this is your boy zinio and i'll see you
guys in the next video
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]